well my character is an evolutionary
biologist so she's not in the military
like these guys but Shane and I
discussed this and I said something it's
really big for me that I think about
before I take on every role is just
microaggression especially when it comes
to like how we portray women in the
media for so long and it's sometimes a
small thing it's not a big statement
it's just a small thing so whenever in
you've seen movies a guy can pick up a
gun or a shot whatever and he just
automatically knows how to do it and
girls always like I don't know and I
thought well I don't I don't want it to
be proficient because she's not a
soldier but I want her to know how just
the same way that guys know how unless
it's not address it so and Shane was
completely down for that you know part
of the original predator to me was that
there was a perfect fusion it was a
piece of perfect pop art right it's the
alien craze of the 80s and the Rambo
craze together and there was a kind of a
wink to it also because you have these
super muscular guys with weapons that
were absolutely ridiculous so this one
we decided for the leaner kind of meaner
approach of a dirty half-dozen and then
the misfits basically and that applies
equally to there's a kid in the movie on
the autism spectrum there's a sort of
misanthropic scientist beautifully
played by Olivia Munn who likes dogs
better than people and they're all sort
of these misfits who've come together
one of the conceits that we had and we
sat down to make this was that we assume
that there's a faction on the predator
homeworld
that's been bested not once but twice
my Earthlings they send their champions
to earth and they don't come home they
don't like that so we figured they want
to punch back what we've focused on is
just this one instance in which a
particular group of particularly angry
predators have managed to formulate
something as they're sort of assassin
there's sort of upgraded weapon but I
think it's not about a xenomorph it's
not about an experiment that's going to
emerge from anyone's chest or
what-have-you although I don't think AVP
is dead do you I love the idea of those
two ba-baby who I like to make people
laugh a little bit like honestly
watching these guys and watching that
scene in particular I
got jealous and the best way possible
because my characters a bit of a lone
wolf throughout the trajectory of the
film but they had such a camaraderie and
had so much fun and every once in a
while I get a chance to hang out with
them and it would be an absolute blast
but for the most part I was by myself I
like doing different stuff every single
time any time somebody tries to put you
into a box and say like this is what
sterling Brown does I like to give them
something a little different so I think
Shane for giving me an opportunity to do
something a little bit different so I
like it all I spent prouder than 25 26
years trying to distance myself from
being lumped in with and hey you know
everyday it's you has anyone ever told
you you look like Gary Busey no wow
thanks for God thanks for telling me
that I hadn't seen a mirror and ever so
after spending these all these years of
trying to build a career in the film
industry and not just be lumped in with
him this comes along and it's really the
coup de Gras it's the moments the moment
of like if I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do it all the way and have Shane call me
and say with this idea what do you think
I was like hell yeah
let's do it so I'm the same age in this
movie that my dad was understand how we
got anything done because we just had we
we were having fun all the time and my
favorite thing I being on a film set is
building a culture is building a look at
almost an instant culture so we spend a
lot of time watching YouTube videos
together we spend a lot of time when
people would come into my trailer and we
would watch a black exploitation movies
so we'd watch Dolomites movies and we
will watch we watch the room and and
then we and then we would do everything
in our power to try to get some moment
through those movies into our movie yeah
there's a moment in in this this video
where this guy does this thing where he
points to somebody like this we tried in
every single take of this movie to get
this movement in the movie and I think
we might have gotten one in I I don't
know yet but I mean there's just some
guys the aliens over there but I think
if we stay over here I got
gun you take the ganado make it to the
choppa we gotta get over here
unbeknownst to Shane since there's been
several predator movies and one obvious
glaring what if who would be who was the
alien versus Predator which begs the
obvious question ripley versus minute Oh
Ripley is dope Wrigley's though Ripley
would find a way
rip Ripley would definitely win come on
Tate alright let's stick with this theme
han Solo
we got a Yoda in there already
definitely the predator oh snap wait
he's just a good pilot he's I said
predator versus a good pilot the
predator will kill him though easily
yeah let's not get too old like the
predator is strong he's these formidable
Han Solo's just charismatic I think the
actually competitor loses both of those
for the because you lose this to
Deadpool for the same reason he loses to
Wolverine he can strike a strike instead
pull a little bit longer to recover
depending on the injury you know to me
people defeat the predator through guile
not through strength because he's just
stronger I think the predator kills
whoever's in front of him because yeah I
don't I don't think by the way I'll go a
little controversial I don't think
there's a single option that's been
discussed in this pre-conference thing
here that would actually win against
this predator
you